[Music]
next five more my 100 tips to help you
cook better
kicking off with how to whip cream
whipping cream
now the important part here is whipping
the cream to a three-quarter stage
if we over whip it it will split so be
very careful
double cream in now when we whisk things
we whisk it in the shape of a figure of
eight and if you spin the bowl
as you whip the cream you get to release
it from the bottom so it whips evenly
whisk whisk whisk and it should just sit
inside the whisk
and start to sort of fall out just
perfect
three-quarter stage double cream done
room temperature cream whips much faster
than cold so you'll need to take your
cream out of the fridge
30 minutes before you want to whip it
unless of course you want to work on
your biceps
a great tip to prevent milk and cream
from boiling over in a saucepan
is to simply lay a wooden spoon across
the top the cream bubbles will rise up
and hit the wooden handle and then fall
back into the pan instead of bubbling
over
sticky stuff like trickle and golden
syrup can be a real mess to measure out
my tip is to rub the spoon with a
neutral oil like rapeseed
and any sticky ingredients will slide
straight off
[Music]
and my tip for greasing cake tins is to
keep old butter wrappers on hand
and use them to crease when needed
[Music]
with how to handle pastry lightly flour
the surface
pastry on top rolling pin now the secret
now
is don't overwork the pastry firm push
turn the pastry round and this helps to
even the pastry turn
and roll now as it starts to crack
don't worry just by pushing it back
together it sort of unites the pastry
immediately
apply pressure turn the pastry
now the average thickness is down to a
one pound coin
back on to the rolling pin and look
beautiful for the neatest edge on tarts
and quiches
my tip is to let the pastry hang over
the side of the tin when you bake it
trim around the edge once the pastry is
cooked it will give you a cleaner edge
and prevent it from shrinking
my tip for even rising is to place cakes
and tarts in the center of the oven
so the air can circulate all the way
around them
to test your cake to make sure it's done
insert a knife
skewer or even a piece of spaghetti in
the center if there's mixture stuck to
it
it's not done yet if it comes out clean
your cake's ready
[Music]
if you don't have any baking beans to
hand for blind baking you can use any
rice
grain or pulse you won't be able to cook
with them afterwards
but do keep them to reuse them next time
when you're folding egg whites and
whipped cream into cake mixtures you
want to retain as much air in the
mixture
as you can my tip use a metal spoon
as the sharp thin edge will keep more of
the air in
[Music]
starting with how to cook dark breasts
perfectly the slow way
duck breasts never be scared about
cooking this bird absolutely delicious
very healthy
first oven on 200 degrees and then
salt pepper now the salt
will help to extract the water out of
the fat
nonstick pan no oil but start the duck
breasts
in the pan cold skin side down
it feels and sounds a little bit weird
but if you put them into a cold pan and
turn the heat up gradually it starts to
release the fat
if we put them into a hot pan it seals
them in and the fat stays in there we
want to render that fat down
90 of that duck breast will be cooked on
its skin keeps the duck nice and moist
but more importantly
it stays crispy once the fat comes out
turn the duck over nice high
hot heat seal the duck
now they're going in the oven skin side
down
six to eight minutes if your pan's got a
plastic handle
then transfer the duck breast onto a
tray but make sure you put the tray into
the oven
to get hot first
cooking duck is like cooking a piece of
beef and you can't slice it piping hot
all the goodness runs out
just quickly turn it over push your
fingers in there and it's
slightly resistant but still quite
bouncy
and that confirms they're quite pink in
the center
but the important part now is leaving
that to rest let them cool down
and then we'll slice them keep
that excess duck fat and there you go
next time you're sauteing potatoes
you just take them to a completely
different level now slicing the dirt
just slice it at an angle not too thin
if you slice it thinly it goes cold
quickly so nice thick slices
nice crispy skin on top and a beautiful
clump roasted duck all the white fat
gone nice crispy skin
absolutely delicious
[Music]
another slow cooking tip is when slow
cooking stews and casseroles fat will
rise to the surface to get rid of any
excess oils
my tip is to remove them with kitchen
paper before serving
[Music]
this also works brilliantly on gravies
and sauces
many great slow-cooked dishes start by
browning the meat
as the meat cooks lots of flavors get
stuck to the pan
to get it into your sauce deglaze with
wine stock or vinegar
never add soft herbs at the beginning
not slow cooking they're all too
delicate
the tip is to add them at the end for
that hit of fresh flavor and vibrant
color
a great tip when frying fish is to
always fry skin side down to keep it
crispy
and always lay the footage away from you
when adding to the pan
to prevent hot oil from splashing
towards you first
how to make a fantastic chicken stock a
classic slow cooked recipe
that gets amazing flavor from simple
ingredients
chicken stock the vital ingredient to
good cooking it transforms
sauces it's a fantastic base for soups
and more importantly it's so easy to do
a little bit of love and care at the
beginning and it cooks itself
right step one chicken carcass into a
pie-sided pan
an onion doesn't need to be finely
chopped
the vegetables flavor the stock
onion in then from there
cut your leek into nice big solid chunks
roughly
same size as the onion so
the vegetables cook at the same time and
then
our carrot celery in
garlic and then
a nice sprig of thyme that helps to
really give
depth of flavor to the chicken stock a
couple of bay leaves
and some fresh parsley
and then peppercorns pan
and just lightly crush them and a little
pinch of salt
and now just cover the vegetables and
the carcass with cold water
just cover the chicken and the
vegetables
bring it up to the ball as quick as you
can
now as it comes into the boil a really
nice skin take the base
of the ladle and swell that around that
pushes
all the grease and the impurities to the
side of the pan
then get your ladle and just tilt it if
you don't skim
all that off the stop becomes very
cloudy
people's impression of cooking stock
then it needs to cook for three four
hours at a time
this is one chicken carcass let that
boil away gently for 30
to 40 minutes maximum
now we're going to pass it off
take a sieve place that over
the pan and then just
pour that in it smells amazing
it's aromatic the color
is absolutely beautiful and there you
have
the most amazing stock
when you need to season meat in flour a
great tip is to place it in a plastic
bag
to dust it evenly using flour also helps
the sauce
to get nice and thick during cooking
when browning meat fry in small batches
don't crowd the pan otherwise it won't
sear or color properly
when slow roasting meat line the bottom
of the roasting tray
with chunky vegetables like onions
fennel and carrots
they act as a trivet to keep the meat
from boiling in his own juices
plus the veg can be the base for your
gravy later on
after slow cooking baked on residue can
be tough to remove
but if you boil water in the pan it will
dissolve and break down
then simply pour out and wash with soap
and water
[Music]
i absolutely love these peppers now they
have the most amazing sweet delicious
flavor
with a really nice crunchy texture and
the most exciting thing about the
peppers is that they're just as
delicious
raw or cooked to identify the perfect
pepper must be smooth and firm
and not a wrinkle inside now how to cut
the perfect pepper
stalk off pepper down and get the knife
start from the top and slice all the way
around
basically we're gonna be slicing around
the seeds
look no faffing around like this little
perfect christmas tree of seeds and you
haven't got the mess all over your board
and more importantly it's twice as quick
discard that
now we're going to cut it into a
julienne flatten the pepper
skin side down onto the board because
it's a lot easier to slice through the
pepper
and just lift the knife up and down
and basically julienne is a chef's word
for strips these
are absolutely perfect for sauteing and
that's what we're looking for there
crunchy delicious and more importantly
no seeds
beautiful
many great brunch recipes start with a
delicious fresh egg
my tried and tested way to tell if your
egg is fresh is to simply place it into
a bowl of cold water
a fresh egg will sink and a stale one
will float
if a small piece of shell goes into the
bowl when you're cracking eggs my tip
for removing it is to simply use a
larger piece
to fish it out it works like magic
for prize winning fried eggs fry them in
oil adding a tablespoon of water
then cover the water steams the top of
the egg to perfection
toasted bagels are brilliant for brunch
my tip to make sure you always have them
on hand
is to stock up your freezer but make
sure you slice them first
that way you can pop them straight into
your toaster
first up how to peel and cut a mango the
easy way
holding your stalk end up cut either
side of the stone cut all the way
into the flesh making squares without
cutting through the skin
then turn it inside out and carefully
cut your pieces off
a great tip to check if a pineapple is
ripe is to pull a leaf out from the top
if it comes away easily it's ripe and
ready for slicing
my tip to get the flesh out of a kiwi is
to simply cut the fruit in half
and scoop it out with a teaspoon try it
it really works
if you have fruit that's not perfectly
ripe the tip is to put a banana in a
paper bag
then add your unripe fruit put in a dark
place and the banana
will speed up the ripening process of
the other fruit
you can make a grapefruit puree to
accompany a brunch pancake or a crumpet
in a blender
to clean it afterwards add a cup of warm
water and run the machine
for a few seconds empty out then simply
repeat with a drop of washing up liquid
then rinse this has to be the most
popular part of the chicken
now very versatile incredibly tender
very lean hardly any fat
whatsoever the secret is cooking it
without it becoming dry
the first thing is to season it properly
both sides
two tablespoons of olive oil get the pan
nice and hot
the secret now is to get a really nice
color on the skin
really nice color no color no flavor
skin side down tilt the pan so it cooks
the back of the chicken breast where
it's really nice and round and very fat
let the pan do the work
chicken breast normally takes between
sort of 10 and 12 minutes to cook
properly
now we've got the color on the skin the
skin's nice and crispy we're going to
deglaze the pan
deglaze with masala now masala is a
sweet fortified italian wine
you can also use white wine masala in
flambe burn off the alcohol
which gets rid of that really sort of
harsh alcoholic flavor
roll the chicken around the masala
delays in the pan basically means
washing the pan
and lifting off all that flavor stuck to
the bottom of the frying pan
and putting it into the sauce now
chicken stock
bring that up to the boil and let it
simmer for three to four minutes
[Music]
it's really important to leave the
chicken breast skin side up the skin's
nice and crispy and it's important now
the chicken cooks from underneath as it
starts cooking
it absorbs the stock so in the center of
the chicken stays nice and moist
[Music]
now the stock of the masala has reduced
down you have the confidence to allow it
to almost disappear
and look the combination between the
masala and the chicken stock
is quite sweet so it finishes the
chicken with this really nice delicious
glaze on top
and there you go a delicious succulent
chicken breast with the most amazing
flavoursome skin phenomenal
soups make stunningly simple meals my
tip for adding incredible depth of
flavor
is to always keep your leftover parmesan
rinds store them in the freezer
then add to the pan as the soup cooks
and leaves to infuse
then remove before serving is less waste
and more taste
another tip to take homemade soup to the
next level whisk in cubes of cold butter
just before serving to get a glossy
velvety texture
and a beautifully rich taste another
fantastic standard for a fuss-free
weekend eat
is the classic baked potato my tip for a
great crispy skin
is to use salt to your advantage simply
add it to the outside before cooking
and the salt will draw out the moisture
in the oven as it bakes
a touch of salt gives you an amazingly
crisp skin on chicken and fish too
as well as highlighting the flavor
[Music]
home roasted nuts make a delicious tv
snack my tip for peeling them with these
is to simply toast them in the oven for
about 10 minutes wrap in a tea towel
and rub until the skins are removed
perfect sprinkle with sea salt
and so with a glass of wine
chopping herbs the secret is to chop
them not bruise them now basil
this is a soft herb so treat it with
some respect when people go mad chopping
herbs all the goodness comes out on the
board
i want the goodness left inside the
basil place them all
inside one another with the largest
leaf at the bottom and it's almost like
rolling a cigar
large one at the bottom small ones in
the center and then look
place them down together just roll them
nice and gently don't bruise them
step one rolled ready to slice
sharp knife imperative fingers tucked in
the bottom part of your knuckle is the
guide
between you and the herbs that there
stops you from cutting your finger
really important to get comfortable with
a knife and just practice
rolling the knife across the board and
relaxing that wrist
it's all in the wrist action so herbs
up fingernails tucked
underneath and just up and down up and
down
and there you have a chopped basil
that's not bruised
and smelling very fragra right
coriander so you get the bunch of
coriander hold it down
and just lightly shave the leaves off
the stalks
bunch them up together and then just
again let the knife
do the work take the fingernails in and
just chop once
and once early don't hack it just chop
it
you can always identify when you bruise
the herb when you've removed the herbs
off the board there's a big green patch
mmm full of flavour and none of the
goodness
is left on the chopping board a great
tip for using leftover herbs
simply chop finely mix into butter roll
up in clim film and freeze
then when you want a herbie hit cut into
slices and melt over steaks
chicken or veg
asparagus is great for a simple supper
to prepare always remove the lower woody
stem
by gently bending and the asparagus will
snap
at the perfect point then boil or steam
and serve with a little of my herb
butter
for a cracking soft boiled egg simply
place your egg in boiling water
add a splash of vinegar and cook for
exactly eight minutes
then plunge into ice water the vinegar
helps the shell peel off easily
and the ice water stops the egg from
cooking giving you the perfect runny
yolk
[Music]
for fuss-free salad dressings simply add
the ingredients into a jam jar
screw the lid on tightly and shake to
combine in seconds
there's no need to wash up a whisk and
the jars ready made
to store any leftovers with how to
prepare
prawns to prep it
get the head and twist keep hold of
those heads
make the most amazing stock and then
with your thumb get underneath the shell
and just peel off that beautiful little
layer
now with your thumb on your finger push
and shake
and look the whole tail comes off you
don't have to peel the whole thing
from there get your knife
and just gently cut the surface of the
prawn
and what we're looking for there is that
little dirt sack that's got to come out
otherwise if you cook
the prawn with that sack in there it's
crunchy it's not very nice and it ruins
that sweet flavor
and there you go the most amazing prawn
ready
for cooking serving whole fish
always makes an impact here's how to
fillet it at the table
run a knife along the backbone remove
the skin
and carefully lift off the portions of
flesh using a fish slice
then just lift off the backbone in one
careful
movement whole hams are always
impressive
to carve one easily hold the hand by the
bone and cut down the meat as close to
the bone as possible
you can then lay your cut hand flat on
the board making it nice and easy to
slice
thinly and evenly
for perfect pork crackling pour over hot
oil before roasting in the oven
it'll come out beautifully crisp and
crunchy
and when you need to chill wine fast
simply add a large handful of salt to
your ice bucket
the salt reduces the freezing point of
the water which will chill your wine
in six minutes flat scallops
are a fantastic ingredient when you want
a special salad that really impresses
here's how to prepare them do not be
intimidated trying to get the scallop
out i'll show you
how easy it is to take them out and how
much more exciting it is to get them
fresh
in the shell so just basically dessert
spoon and a blunt knife
put the knife in to the bottom and you
just twist
open
tilt the knife up so it doesn't cut into
the scallop meat run the knife
from the top to the base
off of the lid no flesh on there and
then from there
that's called the scallop skirt all you
do is just peel that forward
and get the spoon to run down the back
of the shell and the idea is to remove
that little bit of muscle that holds the
scallop
onto the bottom shelf bang it pops out
that's the top
the small side to the bottom there's the
muscle there
and your thumb just slides neatly in
there
and run your fingers round and you just
pop out
scallop and look bang
beautiful this bit here is called the
skirt no use doesn't taste everything
now that's the coral you can slice that
off
dry it in the oven and use it as a
powder for your risottos or even
seasoning fish with
but that's the money these just need to
be rinsed
under cold water dried and ready for the
pan
tomatoes are another salad staple here's
how to skin them for extra refinement
score each one with a cross at the
bottom
blanch in boiling water for a minute
then shot them in cold water
and the skins will easily peel away
pomegranates are a fabulous fruit for
adding glamour to salads or desserts
the trick to getting the seeds out slice
in half lengthways
make slits around the edge turn upside
down over a bowl
and using a large spoon whack as hard as
you can
to release the seeds
[Music]
to take fabulous fruit puts the next
level my tip is to add sophisticated
cornells of ice cream
or lemon mascarpone simply dip two metal
spoons in hot water
scoop shape and add
[Music]
and after baking never throw out your
leftover pastry
it's easily transformed into grapefruit
or savoury party nibbles
roll out grate parmesan
or sprinkle over your favorite fruit
roll and then just slice and bake
you